mm go impress my name's Brad welcome
back to pom gets Wi-Fi a lot of times
you bros are like oh yeah we want more
of this game and we want more of that
but if with this game you bros were like
we will [ __ ] cut off your balls and
feed them to you if you don't play more
of this so huh I'm playing more we're
trying to cross the bridge
but we [ __ ] cancer do you mind moving
aside on it but trying to cross that
bridge behind you no can do
we've been in this line for an awful
long time now and it'd be simply
terrible if we lost our place here you
can have these old Baris SAT books as
our apology wait we don't want these
mama isn't the way the first two days
splendid not a cloud in the sky as usual
discounted gone were standing on of
course of course they're ignoring you
they just unloaded a bunch of crap they
don't wanna know goddamnit
so how the [ __ ] are we gonna move I
can't wait to go to the park I'm going
to train hard and become stronger good
luck with that I feel like that was a
reference to something Pokemon I don't
what is it you dumb she be well if you
use this rock thing as leverage climb
over the fence we have these books right
oh okay see if we stack them on the
wrong it's a little taller same not tall
enough now yeah looks like we have to
get more start the second we're on a
quest to stack [ __ ] on top of each other
sounds like minecraft what is this
wouldn't it be funny if Gary had to
carry around a rose this big bag is Gary
I know Gary you know Gary come on if you
watch my channel good enough you should
know Gary good enough I don't look it up
all right it's gonna Oh help I'm trapped
you okay don't you see there's a spider
over there you mean that little pixel
that black speck it's tiny
no but a puddle takes care of the
spiders but she's not home why don't you
just go kill it with the tissue what if
you try to get it and it dodges
this is very true and then crawls into
my pot yeah come on it's not gonna have
any crawling
I'll die that's impossible
okay grating spidered today you meet
your doom
can't we just coax it outside there's no
real needed killers
now then it might make more spiders you
have to kill it for fun it had big flame
yes thank you thank you thank you you
don't have to shout huh what's with all
this commotion leave to just save my
life not really it I should be thanking
you bet
here have this for saving tres lives
[Music]
okay
a large inflatable dolphin thanks I
guess
we could use it to sack all right let's
do it actually let's say with a fabulous
dog in a little second not trying to go
around him and trying to save on him
okay let's see if we work stacking this
dolphin you stack the larger flesh how
the hell they were retiring that thing
is similar large enough what else do we
need
do you have anything we might be able to
borrow actually I happen to have this
giant potted cactus on me right now how
do you just happen to have something
like that yeah and it's so spiky that's
okay
Editora palm please your stranger stuff
how do I know I can trust you to with it
doesn't the fact that we're in heaven
prove that we're good dogs there's no
such thing as bad dog only bad owners
and bad upbringing that's actually true
so every dog in sup you regardless of
whether you turn out to be trustworthy
owner
how do we get you to trust us then how
about you run an errand for me
do you know papi she owes me a few dog
treats can you ask her for them for me
I'll do her we'll do our best but the
hell is papi this little [ __ ]
hand over the dog treats a daylight
robbery no no no we're hey I'm gold is
behalf she set her hair to retrieve the
dog treats yo ha Oh about that I already
ate them yeah damn it
. bloody microwave okay what do we do
now how about you give her this is that
Famicom I guess we have to take this
back to Goldie and explain what happened
what the hell is a Famicom feel like I
don't get half the references in this
game I know my role is crazy about the
Black Butler reference in the last one
all right let's go here you're back
where are the truths about that Papa
told us she'd eaten them all
she gave us this instead you gave Goldie
the Famicom it's not our fault
alistair dog toxic air please give us
the giant cactus calm down
I was testing you two and you passed
with flying colors I can see you two
second stuff on that rock thing over
there you know
that's why you want the part of cactus
correct yeah but it's not really good to
walk over a [ __ ] potted cactus I
don't know about you bros but I wouldn't
walk on it that's right but why didn't
you just use the fabric huh the bottom
is very flat and way better than second
and I don't know what if I become is
didn't even think about using it you
were so determined to make me trust you
that you were totally distracted from
your original goal honestly that's kind
of adorable
I know oh stop it you good yeah you can
have this farm again yes you stack the
fabric on into the rock thing oh is that
all right let's you two over there what
do you think you're doing ah [ __ ] the
poop again can't tell me what you do
Xena since then whatever adios [ __ ]
I [ __ ] love her palm is like the best
character ever oh [ __ ] [ __ ] are you okay
you were knocked out by the super-fast
fish before a while don't be where it's
so we're in the back me it's gross okay
Yolo I get it I did reach end succeed or
job for that frisbee best voice acting
ever sorry oh hey wake up you two what
oh so you finally regained consciousness
I
[Music]
what are you two doing here Charmian
sent me to go after you when you climbed
over the fence when I found you you were
both lying there knocked out by the
precipice we are here to try to fix that
frisbee machine is that so it's gonna
eat us
run oh I'm not gonna hurt you not gonna
lie at first I thought you two were up
to no good but it seems like you're
actually trying to help why don't we
work together um huh
we can actually see that from your name
being displayed many times
yes but whatever and this shitty-ass
excuse for a man sir put it over here is
Sebastian I'm cheap oh and who are you
calling a manservant nice to meet you
yeah Haase is part of the party now
apparently I don't know [ __ ] one this
is it awkwardly close to us what is this
Oh looks like an opening into the
machine there should be a control packet
in there they'll resetting
I'm Way too big to fit inside now me too
I can't eat this all looks like it was
made for me then I guess and I get its
house and I are going to be left by a
semi Merry Christmas
[Music]
whatever you say look at the time
it's y'all what's what is she talking
about she says she'd never buy it it's
nothing
pod you're drooling a little oh well who
can blame me just lame-o write it yeah
Merry Christmas hey it's a dust bunny
looks more like a dust turd
speaking of turd don't you think she
pissed tails shake luck I haven't
noticed that lets me good oh that works
okay holy Shih Tzu this dust is so old
that it is solid it'll be fine I'm not
small enough to worm my way through
that's a control panel anything of it
yes there's nothing to do but to turn
back to walking this is where that
frisbee are coming from so fast sonic
would be jealous
sonic would be jealous
got places to go gotta follow my rainbow
follow me set me free trust me and we
escape from the city I should sing that
song on American Idol
[Music]
you
why are you making weird noises I was
trying to scare you
you're always scare me why are they like
that Wow
I'm all gross and dusty now don't wipe
your filthy paws on me Oh high price I'm
gonna have to end this episode hey I
hope you enjoyed watching never liked if
you're dead it helps me out a lot I
can't wait to see what else is gonna
happen so I'll see you tomorrow
love you
[Music]